♪ ♪ ♪
- À 230 km au nord de Montréal,
on arrive dans la capitale
des Hautes-Laurentides :
Mont-Laurier.
Avec un peu plus de 14 000
habitants, c'est la ville
la plus populeuse dans le vaste
territoire de la MRC d'Antoine-
Labelle. Région réputée pour la
chasse et la pêche, le magasin
Le Coureur des bois est
un incontournable pour
les passionnés de la nature.
Lui, c'est François Labelle,
le propriétaire depuis 40 ans.
FRANÇOIS LABELLE, propriétaire,
Le Coureur des Bois
- Je vais te montrer
le frigidaire à sangsues.
- L'homme est connu ici,
notamment pour son élevage
de sangsues, qui fait fureur
auprès des pêcheurs.
- Quand tu la mets dans tes
mains comme ça puis elle tourne,
c'est parce qu'elle est vraiment
bien vivante.
- Et les affaires sont bonnes.
Les articles de plein air
ont la cote et sa clientèle
est plus nombreuse.
- Depuis l'an passé, avec
l'arrivée de la pandémie,
c'est... la région a été
submergée de tout le monde.
On voit qu'il y a encore plus
de monde chaque année qui monte
de plus en plus, parce qu'on
le voit qu'il y a plus de monde
dans la région.
- En effet : au cours
des dernières années, il y a eu
plus d'arrivées que de départs
dans les Laurentides. Le solde
migratoire de la MRC d'Antoine-
Labelle est passé de 94 en 2019
à 550 en 2020.
Roberto et Julie font partie
de ces nouveaux arrivants.
Ils se sont rencontrés il y a
un an. Ils ont décidé de quitter
Montréal et de s'acheter
cette maison située
à Ferme-Neuve, en banlieue
de Mont-Laurier.
JULIE MALO BOUCHARD
- Moi, Mont-Laurier,
à part sur une pancarte verte,
je n'avais jamais vu ça.
Fait que pour moi, c'était fou.
- Un changement radical qui
s'est passé très rapidement.
- J'ai dit : Ok, Roberto,
comme, j'ai une promesse d'achat
dans les mains, il faut que
je la signe et que je l'envoie,
là, comme, c'est-tu vrai!
- Bien oui, on signe!
(rires)
- Il m'a dit : "Bien oui,
envoie-la!"  J'étais comme : OK,
c'est bon! Fait que on l'a fait.
- Une douce folie que le couple,
qui travaille en immobilier,
ne regrette pas.
- Il y a des gens qui disent :
"Ah! c'est mon projet de
retraite." Bien, c'est pas
obligé d'être ton projet
de retraite, ça peut être
ton projet de vie aussi.
ROBERTO VIDAL
- Moi, j'avais vraiment le désir
d'essayer un nouveau mode de vie
aussi. La ville, je connais,
aller au café du coin, aller
au restaurant, tout ça.
Puis avec le déconfinement,
je me disais : J'ai pas le goût
de retourner vraiment à ce mode
de vie-là. Fait que je pense
qu'on est aux balbutiements
d'une prise de conscience
que la région a une valeur.
Je savais que, si on déménageait
dans une petite ville comme ici,
on était pas loin de toute
une activité économique
quand même que je pense
qui est en développement.
Je croyais en la région.
- Et justement, depuis cinq ans,
Mont-Laurier est en pleine
transformation.
La revitalisation
du centre-ville est en cours,
un investissement
de 8 millions $; la route 117,
qui traverse la ville,
sera modernisée; une salle de
spectacles multifonctionnelle
a été construite au coût
de 19 millions $; on projette
aussi de fournir Internet haute
vitesse sur tout le territoire
d'ici 2022; sans oublier le parc
industriel de plus de 4 millions
de pieds carrés qui est
en plein essor.
DANIEL BOURDON,
maire de Mont-Laurier
- Depuis 2018 qu'on a décidé
de le développer parce
qu'on n'avait aucune entreprise
dans notre parc industriel.
- Après 25 ans sans activité,
les choses bougent enfin.
L'entreprise Forex prévoit
construire une importante usine
de transformation du bois.
- Ça va être historique
pour la ville de Mont-Laurier.
Ils vont investir dans le parc
industriel 220 millions
pour créer 150 emplois en usine.
Alors pour nous, moi, je vous
en parle et j'en ai la chair
de poule parce que
notre population en a besoin.
Notre terrain, notre parc
industriel, va falloir commencer
à regarder pour en acheter
un autre.
- Ah oui?
- Oui, tout à fait parce que...
- Ça se développe à ce point?
- Ah, oui! À part l'usine
de Forex, on a aussi une autre
usine qui est de bioproduits
aussi, qu'eux autres, c'est
50 millions environ. Alors
vous voyez, il y a beaucoup
d'effervescence. Puis un autre
beau projet qu'on a, qu'on
supporte, c'est l'implantation
de l'Université du Québec
en Abitibi-Témiscamingue, qui,
l'année prochaine, vont investir
10 millions $ à Mont-Laurier
pour la construction
d'un nouveau pavillon.
On travaille pour avoir
des jeunes, parce que pas juste
des gens de mon âge,
ça prend des jeunes.
- Érik Tardif est
l'un de ces jeunes que
le maire tente d'attirer.
Natif de Montréal, il est venu
s'installer ici il y a cinq ans.
Il est devenu un fier
ambassadeur de la région.
ÉRIK TARDIF, propriétaire
de la charcuterie Les Bucherons
- Quand je suis venu visiter,
c'était vraiment le coup
de foudre avec la belle-famille,
mais aussi vraiment
avec la région.
- Il a démarré son entreprise
de charcuterie, un changement
de vie complet pour cet ancien
charpentier.
- Pour moi, c'est une grosse
fierté de me dire charcutier,
veut dire je suis capable de
faire du saucisson sec de façon
traditionnelle, ça fait que
j'ai parti un élevage de porcs
juste pour faire ces saucissons-
là dans la région.
Pour moi, c'est tout, c'est
vraiment... c'est mon âme
qui est mis là-dedans puis
c'est le travail de mon équipe,
c'est un travail d'années.
- Il a maintenant 13 employés,
dont son nouveau chef
fraîchement arrivé de Montréal.
Et sa dernière réalisation...
- Vous avez besoin de
deux tables, dans le fond?
- ... un restaurant qui offre
exclusivement des produits
régionaux.
- Moi, je suis heureux
de qu'est-ce qui se passe,
spécialement dans le dernier
un an et demi, on a vraiment
énormément de monde qui vont
venir de l'extérieur et
décider de s'établir ici.
Mont-Laurier va revenir
un peu à sa gloire que peut-être
elle était quand l'industrie
forestière était vraiment
énorme, puis elle avait
vraiment... il y avait vraiment
un gros boom ici.
Et effectivement, l'industrie
forestière a vraiment pris un...
a vraiment chuté pas mal,
mais on devient une région
agrotouristique, ça fait que là,
on montre qu'on a autre chose
à offrir.
FRÉDÉRIC HOULE, dg Centre local
développement d'Antoine-Labelle
- Dans cinq ans, notre pari,
c'est que Mont-Laurier
ait totalement un autre visage.
- Depuis 12 ans, Frédérick Houle
travaille pour développer
l'entrepreneuriat.
Une campagne publicitaire
a été lancée l'an dernier
pour attirer les jeunes.
- Fut un temps que dans
la région, c'était plus
des entrepreneurs par nécessité.
Maintenant, j'ai vraiment des
gens qui ont l'entrepreneuriat
dans l'âme. À tous les jours,
sans exagérer, j'ai un nouveau
client qui veut
qu'on l'accompagne.
- Les offres d'emplois dans
la MRC ont doublé en un an.
- En 2021, à date, 700 offres
d'emplois qui ont été publiées
sur le territoire, tant pour
des gens qui ont zéro scolarité
que des gens qui ont
de la scolarité au niveau
universitaire. C'est incroyable,
le nombre de personnes
qu'on recherche actuellement
pour combler des postes
et de tout genre! Le travail
et les vacances, il y a
une différence, mais il y a
moyen de faire les deux
la même journée.
- Un concept que le maire
maîtrise parfaitement : aller
pêcher en plein centre-ville,
à cinq minutes du bureau.
- Je pense que les gens, quand
ils vont arriver ici, ils vont
tomber en amour avec la qualité
de vie. C'est pas une vie
qui est stressante, loin de là.
- Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, Mont-Laurier.